salut séjour de laser si vous suivez un
petit peu c'est la sixième séance
si vous suivez pas c'est la septième
séance quand même sauf que vous suivez
pas c'est pas très sympa
bon alors je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué récemment à chaque séance je
prends soin de poser une petite question
pour agrémenter la vidéo cette fois je
vais demander au médecin qui est très
sympa s'il pense que il va me rester des
petites traces ou s'ils pensent que veut
vraiment tout va partir
voilà je filme et on se retrouve après
[Musique]
ok dafoe
ouais non ça va
on sent qu'il ya des endroits où il en
reste leur reste plus
ça fait deux
claude depuis septembre
[Musique]
ouais ouais
voilà tu survenu c'est terminé même
procédure que d'habitude je vous ferai
pas le tout pour à chaque fois
maintenant potvin d'anesthésiant jato 1h
petite séance rapide une nouvelle fois
fait que les réglages cette fois était à
fond en terme de puissance avec toujours
des temps d'impulsion assez court pour
permettre en effet davantage mécanique
c'est à dire qui cogne plus et moins
thermique c'est à dire qu'ils brûlent
moins donc plus d'efficacité - douleur -
de brûlures donc malgré le fait que
c'était puissance maximale toujours très
peu de douleur voilà en tout cas
beaucoup moins qu'avant
donc ça c'est pour la partie pratique
aux pratiques de la séance par rapport à
la petite question que je m'étais promis
de poser aux médecins à savoir est ce
qu'ils pensent qui va me rester des
traces
j'ai demandé au médecin de ce qu'ils
appellent le docteur christian le mail
si ça vous intéresse
très sympa très compétent très pédagogue
donc je lui ai posé la question et sa
réponse a été sans détour
mais avant de m'attarder sur mon petit
cas personnel je vais vous faire un
petit un petit topo sur ce qui peut
arriver en matière de trafic quand on
fait du laser pour ce faire des
patrouilles alors quand on fait un
détatouage au laser le laser
évidemment il agresse un petit peu la
peau et les tissus et la peau et les
tissus qui se défendent d'une façon qui
est assez classique dans l'organisme par
un mécanisme qui s'appelle
l'inflammation on prend un coup quand on
a une infection quand on me dit quand on
se brûle quand le laser
agressent la peau il ya tout un tas de
mécanismes qui ce qui se passe il ya
tout un tas de substances chimiques qui
entrent en jeu pour venir réparer et
qu'on appelle le processus
d'inflammation
dans toutes ces substances qui
interviennent dans la dans
l'inflammation
il y en a certaines qui stimule des
cellules assez particulière de la peau
et même de l'épiderme pour être précis
qui s'appelle les mélanocytes voilà donc
l'épiderme
c'est l'artiste endroit là et les
mélanocytes ces petites ces petites
cellules qui sont qui sont là ces
mélanocytes leur travail c'est de
fabriquer des pigments on atteint
rapidement notamment qu'on appelle la
mélanine et qui est responsable de la
pigmentation notre peau et qui est
responsable aussi du bronzage par
exemple donc ce qui se passe quand elle
la peau est agressée par le laser
l'inflammation entre en jeu et cette
inflammation stimule les mélanocytes qui
produisent plus de mélanine à l'endroit
où elles sont où la peau a été agressé
c'est ce qu'on appelle une
hyperpigmentation poste inflammatoires
hyperpigmentation trop de pigmentation
poste inflammatoires après une
inflammation
donc en gros c'est là où passe le laser
la peau reste un peu comme bronze et si
vous voulez alors c'est un peu con parce
que le laser comme c'est très précis ça
passe pile sur le tracé du tatouage donc
finalement le machin qui te retires
lancre du tatouage à la place ça te
laisse une espèce de traces de semis
bronzage qu'on appelle poliment des
traces fantôme
donc bon alors il faut savoir que
évidemment plus tu te passe la peau au
laser plus tu as de chances d'avoir ce
type de traces fantôme en plus de
éventuellement ta sensibilité et
personnelles par exemple les peaux mates
ou noirs sont plus sujettes à ce genre
de à ce genre de soucis mais en tout cas
plus tu fais des séances de laser plus
tu risques d'avoir de traces fantôme du
père pigmentation post inflammatoires
inutile de vous dire que moi c'est ma
seizième séance donc je me disais ok bon
donc très clairement
et ben non ça va alors j'en ai un petit
peu on en avait parlé même là
parfois dans la vidéo si vous souvenez
bien j'en ai un petit peu par endroits
mais ça reste très correct et le médecin
à mon sujet n'est pas inquiet si vous
vous souvenez bien je vous en avais
parlé il m'a dit bronzage de bronzage
par là dessus et homophiles de quelques
mois à quelques années au pire ça sort
ça aura complètement disparu si en a
mais il y en a pas beaucoup donc cool
alors si vous voulez voir à quoi ça
ressemble des traces fantôme de l'hyper
pigmentation au poste inflammatoires et
ben le docteur le mail qui est
décidément très sympa m'a gentiment
confié deux photos d'un de ses patients
voilà que je vous montre immédiatement
donc là vous voyez c'est le tatouage
avant et là c'est ce qui reste après
vous voyez cette espèce de petit de
petites ombres qui on revoit quand même
encore bien le tatouage voilà et bah
c'est exactement ça des traceurs les
traces fantôme voit la liasse alors il
ya un autre risque de traces avec le
détatouage au laser c'est le risque
exactement inverse c'est ce qu'on
appelle la dépigmentation donc là vous
avez bien compris c'est des taches
blanches au lieu d'avoir une espèce de
traces bronze et on a des taches
blanches et là c'est tout un tout
simplement le laser qui au lieu de
stimuler les mélanocytes les cellules
qui fabrique des pigments au lieu de les
stimuler par le biais de l'inflammation
là le laser laitue carrément du coup il
ya plus de pigments donc plus de
pigmentation donc plus de coloration de
la peau à cet endroit donc ça fait des
traces toute blanche
ça peut finir par s'en aller il peut y
avoir voilà des solutions
et puis le les mélanocytes peuvent après
ceux de alentours à finir un petit peu
le boulot à la place des collègues qui
sont tombés au combat
c'est un petit peu plus embêtant que les
traces fantôme c'est un petit peu plus
longue mais voilà et alors là pour le
coup en ce qui me concerne aucun
problème je n'ai rien de tout ça donc
voilà
je suis plutôt plutôt rassuré alors
restait une question évidemment c'était
on en est à plus de deux ans on en est à
16 séances neuf séances de pick au jour
et c'est avec l'ancienne technique
donc j'ai aussi demandé aux médecins
est-ce que vous pensez que finalement un
jour ça va s'arrêter cette histoire est
bien là j'ai été aussi assez rassuré oui
lui il reste très très tranquille très
confiant très serein
d'ailleurs on va regarder ça tout de
suite ensemble mais ça continue à
disparaître ça continue à partir
certains traits continue à pâlir
d'autres traits ont disparu voilà en
tout cas c'est au nom n'a jamais été
aussi près de aussi près de la fin on
n'y est pas encore mais voilà je prends
mon nom je prends mon mal en patience
donc voilà évidemment ce que vous
attendez tous les photos où ça s'était
bien quelques semaines maintenant
c'était juste avant la dernière séance
et là c'est aujourd'hui voilà je vous
laisse un peu les deux pour que vous
puissiez comparer et puis bah sur la
photo du jour juste avant la séance du
jour
vous voyez il y a des traits qui
continuent à disparaître gentiment il ya
des endroits comme là où ça a
complètement disparu il ya des endroits
comme là où on voit une petit quelque
chose qui pourrait être comme tâche
fantômes et mais c'est gentillet et puis
il ya des endroits comme la oumma il
reste encore de lancre donc il reste
encore du boulot
donc vous voyez on n'est pas au bout du
chemin
pour le médecin très clairement il ya
des endroits où vraiment il avait eu un
maximum d'entre c'est pour ça que c'est
très long voilà on va pas se mentir
c'est très long parce qu'il ya beaucoup
du coup par contre comme là on a eu
séance puissance maximum ça veut dire
qu'on laisse tout ça au repos pendant
cette fois deux mois donc prochain
rendez vous fin juin après le hellfest
bord bien sûr d'ici là il y aura des
vidéos régulièrement comme d'habitude
donc on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos et en attendant eba
mettez vous bien et puis surtout portez
vous bien
[Musique]